[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 y rosa Pérez más le gusta con
nosotros en el estudio Rosa buena mañana
de miércoles vamos a dedicar la revista
de prensa de hoy ya a mitad de semana a
una selección de artículos sobre lo que
está ocurriendo en daos por supuesto el
foro económico mundial empezamos por el
medio francés media Park en uno de texto
de Matías titulado el Foro de davos cada
vez más desconectado de la realidad
también entre otras cosas un dato que me
llamó muchísimo la atención Es que
muchos de estos líderes pues económicos
del mundo llegaron en sus jets privados
obviando un poco también al discurso de
salvar el planeta en materia de cambio
climático efectivamente Raúl y Esta es
una de las cuestiones que señala este
artículo no y es la desconexión de la
realidad social y ecológico de la mayor
parte del mundo o de todo el mundo bien
empieza este artículo diciendo que el
Foro de davos es la cita anual más
preciada para los poderes económicos
dice más de 2500 Afortunados van a hacer
negocios entre los pasillos de la
pequeña y distinguida estación de esquí
de los alpes suizos y van a asistir a
las conferencias de los altos dirigentes
de grandes compañías como blackrock Axa
Nestlé etcétera y de instituciones
internacionales como el Banco Central
europeo o la Organización Mundial del
Comercio y como bien decías no discursos
que considera este periodista
desconectados de la realidad y que no
abordan los efectos devastadores del
capitalismo financiero dice sin
sorpresas este año el tema de la
desigualdad no va a estar en el centro
del debate siendo a pesar de todo no la
creciente desigualdad una de las
principales características de nuestro
sistema económico capitalista bien dice
no se espera tampoco en davos un
rendimiento de un rendimiento de cuentas
a las grandes afortunas que se
enriquecen no de las crisis no se espera
una respuesta al informe de oxfam de
este pasado 16 no de enero el día que se
inauguraba este foro económico mundial
quedaba la siguiente cifra Y es que la
fortuna de los mil millonarios crece a
un ritmo de 2.700 millones de dólares al
día finalmente dice el periodista hay
que ver el Foro de davos como un lugar
donde hacer negocios y no un lugar donde
resolver los principales retos de la
humanidad no y cierra el texto con el
siguiente párrafo dice en una crónica
para el final Times un comunicador
inglés antiguo consejero en downing
Street que va a davos no dice lo
contrario vamos a hablar de las cinco
razones por las que sí hay que ir a
davos Rosa vamos a ver el texto del Five
Nights en que ruther señala en esta
inutilidad de ir a davos o no con este
artículo Efectivamente es el texto al
que se refería finalmente este artículo
de media Park no dice Rutherford que en
su Crónica en su columna semanal en el
final sal Times recupera algunos de los
mensajes o de los emails que ha recibido
a lo largo de la semana Y a partir de
ahí escribe una columna en este caso
intenta responder era un amigo que le
pregunta si merece la pena ir a davos y
él dice solo hay cinco razones por las
que merecería la pena asistir a davos la
primera porque estás buscando un trabajo
la segunda porque estás intentando hacer
un negocio la tercera porque de verdad
te interesa genuinamente escuchar a
gente exitosa alardear de su
intelectualidad cuarto porque estás y
deseas desesperadamente pasar 10 minutos
con algo o la reina rania de Jordania 5
porque quieres poder decir en futuras
conversaciones o si este Fue una gran
tema de debate en davos este año dice sé
que hay personas que consideran que ir a
davos les va a abrir las puertas a temas
no que van a marcar el mundo en los
futuros años dice pero para eso también
puede leer uno el financial Times que es
más práctico dice en resumen nadie
Necesita ir a davos Pero hay personas
que necesitan Mostrar que son
precisamente el tipo de gente que va a
davos y nosotros precisamente seguimos
leyendo las páginas del final son porque
hay un texto que dice La geopolítica
amenaza con del mundo que davos a creó
es de jiton exactamente y de este
artículo nos hemos querido fijar
solamente en la parte final no que dice
que básicamente cada vez haya más
políticos que consideran que no les sale
a cuenta asistir a davos Y ser
fotografiados con la élite económica
mundial pone el caso de Joe biden que
dice está determinado a mostrarse como
un líder que está del lado de los
estadounidenses trabajadores y que por
lo tanto Pues a Nova a proyectar la
imagen que desea si se codea con los sí
o no digamos de las grandes compañías
mundiales lo mismo macron que tiene
sobre la mesa está polémica reforma de
las pensiones o Richie sunat También
alguien que viene del mundo de las
finanzas pero que también tiene huelgas
constantes en su país el que sí nos
asistió además de usted y yo Rosa que
estamos acá en la ciudad de Bogotá fue
elonmasco exactamente y él dijo que no
asistía no porque considerara que fuera
davos digamos el epicentro de una
conspiración diabólica mundial como
alguna gente considera sino porque
parece bastante aburrido sin embargo los
organizadores del foro acaban de
confirmar que de hecho y lo más no
recibió ninguna invitación para asistir
a davos desde 2015 Pero hay un manual no
para este foro en el medio político Rosa
exactamente los periodistas de político
que están en davos están elaborando una
especie de agenda de manual diario sobre
los temas que marcan la agenda del día
las personas que van a hablar etcétera
Pero esto ya lo comentamos con nuestra
enviada especial Daniela Blandón por lo
que nos vamos a fijar en una parte de
este manual que se llama spot visto no y
muestran algunas de las curiosidades que
observan los periodistas digamos detrás
de bambalinas entre otras cosas señalan
por ejemplo las personas reunidas en tal
coctel no por ejemplo la líder de la
oposición
los rosas Delta Exacto reunida con el
crítico del kremlinder el congresista
demócrata brendan
el director del m-16 los servicios de
inteligencia británica el director de
cine de cine oliverston la diputada
ucraniana María mercenaba representantes
de JP Morgan o finaliza cinco personas
snifando sustancias en el ex bar de
dagoso bueno Rosa Está buena esa ese
punto final Muchísimas gracias como
siempre mañana Por supuesto con más
revista de prensa hasta mañana